these men are the last to go down into
the mines the elevator takes them more
than a thousand meter below the ground
in a minute and a half
this mine near Essen in western Germany
is one of the last coal mines in the
country still in operation hard coal
mining will cease in four years Germany
Ruhr district has around 60 million tons
of coal for decades the German
government subsidized coal production
but it is no longer profitable to mine
it here it's cheaper to import coal from
South Africa Russia or Australia the
main problem with abandoned mines and
tunnels is the influx of water thousands
of pumps like these keep water from
flooding the tunnels the pipes stretch
hundreds of kilometers it's important
that they keep working after the mine
closes to ensure that the region's
drinking water isn't contaminated
there's water all around us the pumps
keep the tunnels dry we pump out process
water - if we stop then all of that
water would slowly seep back in the
water's briny
this rock was formed by an ancient ocean
that's why there's salt in the rock we
have to make sure that the brining water
doesn't rise up into our underground
water reservoirs that's where we get our
drinking water around fifty thousand
tunnels pockmark Germany's rural
district like a piece of Swiss cheese
mine pumps keep water level from rising
if they stopped it would only take a
couple of decades before huge lakes
gradually formed it will cost billions
of euros to keep the pumps operating
Germany's former economics Minister
vanam Ulla wants to manage the enormous
project after leaving politics moolah
ran what was once Germany's largest coal
mining company he has all the right
connections and says his foundation
could keep Germany's Ruhr district dry
if you tell me how long people are going
to live here and I'll tell you that we
will pump up until that day I believe
people will live here forever that's why
we will pump forever on this video
right now his foundation derogative
tongue has an endowment of around two
billion euros it generates revenue from
real estate sales and stock investments
it is a successful business model as
long as the dax keeps climbing mullahs
plan in theory could work but it is
impossible to calculate risks for the
endless future what will happen if the
money runs out we forecast that our
revenues for the next six years will be
between 350 and 400 million euros given
everything we know the pumps will cost
around 220 million euros that's easy to
calculate one thing we can't determine
specifically is the price for power the
pumps use a lot of electricity as far as
we can predict incoming revenue will
always be a lot higher than our expenses
a lot of people living near the mines
are worried about the future
local farmers say it's getting harder to
make a living
the pumps can't keep groundwater from
flooding the fields after years of
mining the land here is sinking
that's up to gets a photo yeah it means
small lakes or ponds start to appear man
then we get ducks and geese all this
extra water means we can't farm those
areas regularly anymore there are times
when we simply can't plant or harvest
and that has serious economic
consequences for us the prosper Hanyu
coal mine closes in 2018 when that
happens the company will retrain its -
to work in other fields they will become
electricians mechanics and technicians
some could find work operating the pumps
no one knows how much it will cost to
keep the tunnels dry or what will happen
to them in a hundred or maybe a thousand
years